[Musica]
buonasera a tutti piacere si blocca alla
prima iniziare questo discorso che loro
solo dire una cosa io sono uno che parla
molto con la musica e non parla tanto
con la voce iniziale così allora ho
iniziato a 13 anni per puro caso con il
computer di mio padre
girando per caso presenza computer e ho
trovato un programma musicale ma in si
fa a giocarci a quell'età non avevo
tanti hobby giocandoci ho trovato che
era la cosa che volevo fare da piccolo
da grande
quindi mi sono messo un po a giocarci a
mio padre ha visto che ci trova un sacco
di interesse e lui era un rapper quindi
ha detto bravo
secondo me ci possiamo investire su
questa cosa quindi mi ha preso un
computer e un pochino più serio e ci
siamo fatti lo studio in stanza a casa
come potete vedere ecco qua un giovane
look però dopo un dopo un po mio padre
ha detto perché non ci facciamo una cosa
più seria perchè comunque per fare la
musica
servono i cantanti e io a casa non
potevo portare i cantanti che facevano
baccano fumavano casino quindi se facevo
così era un gran problema quindi abbiamo
deciso di prendere uno studio dentro un
garage che sarebbe questo qui io in
questo studio
ho iniziato a trovare la mia vera
passione ho capito che volevo fare
questo non la vedo in questo studio per
fornire un sacco di cantanti fino a che
il giorno non incontrò un gruppo di
ragazzi del nome da paul hogan
eccoli qua come potete vedere un bel
gruppetto di ragazzi coatti romani
quindi eccoci qua
vedi il ragazzo che fu ma se fumava in
casa erano danni insomma ci siamo messi
qua in questo studio a fare tanta musica
dal 2015 al 2017 dello studio questo
studio intanto un gran punto di incontro
per la musica trap la musica trap è la
musica che oggi è più influenti dai
giovani anche tra i grandi
infatti sono passati un sacco di artisti
in questo studio qui potete vedere un
altro artista a teatro oggi isbul sfera
e basta
ho un sacco di gente è passato in questo
studio è uscito un pezzo molto
importante nella trap che si chiama
sportswear e adesso mi farò sentire e
questo pezzo
diciamo che è l'inno della trap ogni
volta che la metto in qualsiasi
discoteca qualsiasi concerto la gente
impazzisce
eccola qui ok
questa canzone è nata il beat è nato in
dieci minuti
allora per scrivere c'erano nessuna
mezz'oretta
questa canzone è la canzone più famosa
nella trappe d'italia per farla ho fatto
questo questo è il suono principale
della canzone
dopo di questo ci ha aggiunto delle
batterie che sarebbero queste qui e
dopodiché ho aggiunto un basso
[Musica]
questo è il corpo della canzone questo
in discoteca e nei locali fa muovere
tutto
e tutto insieme che da questo allora
come vi ho detto
per fare questa canzone ci ho messo
veramente poco ai tempi non si potevano
usare questi tipo di plugin i plugin
sono dei suoni ad esempio come vedete
sullo schermo dei sintetizzatori degli
organi campionatori integrati nel
computer primati servivano ti serviva
uno studio gigante di serve un mixer ti
servono musicisti che venivano a suonare
per te
adesso invece è tutto sul computer
quindi come ho iniziato al garage
chiunque può iniziare a fare musica
basta avere un computer e dei programmi
crackati adesso iniziato a comprarli
però so sincero tassi la verità
dopodiché le farò negazione si ci vuole
poco tempo ma in realtà serve anche una
visione artistica come avete visto ho
messo 4 suoni insieme che sono
pochissimi magari le canzoni che
scortavano gli anni 90 2000 erano
grandissimi composizioni ci ho messo
veramente poco però per farla una
canzone veramente bella di avere una
visione artistica
questa visione artistica di avere dentro
di avere un po di knowledge quindi
avremo uno studio di musica io ascolto
musica da quando sono piccolo io sono
nato a londra e sono cresciuto in
america insieme a mio padre e mio padre
è cresciuto con la musica rap quindi ce
l'ha proprio nel sangue io crescendo
queste cose so più o meno come la storia
della musica trap del rap come farla
quindi in italia ai tempi che hanno
conosciuto la dark non c'era quel tipo
di musica che si chiama trap
quindi abbiamo portato un po di cose
nuove che non c'erano però non bastava
solo la musica
cosa ci ha aiutato a diventare quello
che siamo i social instagram a youtube
prima di noi queste cose non si usavano
tanto cioè si usavano ma non davano una
mano per pubblicizzare quello che facevi
invece ad esempio io che sono un
produttore i produttori prima non erano
come in the face nero non faccia erano
sempre i cantanti essere i principali
invece io grazie a instagram sono
riuscito a diventare un grande
produttore è un grande non vorrei dire
personaggio che non sono che fa ridere
però sono diventato un entità comunque
tutti mi conoscono in italia attraverso
i social e grazie
posso girare l'italia per i concerti e
girare anche il mondo come potete vedere
questo è un concerto ecco qui che valgo
aspetta scusate che ballano la canzone
commesso prima o poi questa è un'altra
scusate linguaggio quel signore che
vedete lì a mio padre
ecco questa è un'altra foto
insomma io se posso fare questo è anche
molto grazie ai social che prima non si
usavano quindi questo periodo nuovo
della vita abbiamo un po cambiato le
cose e per questo anche la tratta è
molto seguito oggi dai giovani però
ovviamente uno dice che la instagram
c'è un computer john graus quindi posso
fare musica può diventare come te però
devi essere bravo di essere devi creare
un po come si dice un personaggio
io ad esempio mi sono sempre ispirato a
altri produttori americani in questo
caso mi che in italia nessuno mi
ispirava nessuno è mai stato un esempio
per me come oggi io sono un esempio per
i ragazzi
quindi io prendevo esempio docter direi
anzi scusate mi è scattato qualcosa
questo sono io gli studi con tanti
rapsel americani era per tornare al
discorso che puoi girare il mondo con la
musica
ecco come vedete questo qui un bel
criminale ecco io mi sono ispirato a
tantissimi produttori americani ad
esempio doctor direi un grande
compositore che ha iniziato con un
gruppo di gangster up e andrew haigh è
andata a finire a produrre dei queen
stefani eminem fifty cent e lui era un
grande e una grande persona ha avuto un
grande occhio verso la musica ha
iniziato a mettere la musica rap nel
musica pop e questa è una cosa che alza
il livello a gente come m dunque che lui
si è creato proprio e che comune
supereroe quindi la gente ancora più
invogliato a sentire questo tipo di
persone che vi fa sentire le storie che
c'hanno non è più solo il cantante che
sta lì
che di solito è il rapper e il cantante
justin timberlake
justin bieber traders capito che non
sempre vedere il l'artista invece in
questo caso il produttore si è bravo e
riesce a trarre la sua entità per
diventare qualcuno
vediamo qui un metro booming un
grandissimo produttore della trap lui
sarebbe un sì clock in america infatti
se vede bene la collana stile un bel
personaggio e questa è una cosa
importante grazie sempre grazie ai
social è tutta ecco questo è stato un po
il mio discorso per farvi capire un po
la trap come la vedo io da produttore
non da cantante
ora io gli volevo finire il discorso
facendo una canzone al momento come vi
volevo dire che possiamo essere anche
noi uno strumento o li farò sentire
ecco scusatemi allora apro qui questa
note faccio una cosa del genere quindi
sono molto teso serie ragazzi riesco a
suonare davanti a duemila persone però
sembrare serie davanti a 350 non è
facile ok allora mi faccio una piccola
nuove di al volo
[Musica]
ok
io così faccio la musica faccio la
melodia mi ispira e dopo di che penso a
cosa ci potrei fare sopra ok
semplicissimo
[Musica]
sopra di questo farò una cosa
particolare
fischierà avevo pensato abbiamo fatto
delle prove oggi è di mettere anche voi
in mezzo ci abbiamo provato con tre
persone e non era assolutamente
fattibile perché molto complicato
feedback valeee ma le cose che non
riuscì a spiegare quindi lo farò io da
solo facciamo questa prova farò un
fischio
[Musica]
ok ora farò come art attack questa era
per far vedere come si fa adesso faccio
vedere quello che può uscire
[Musica]
ok perché io lo fa vedere questo è
perché oggigiorno se voglio poter
prendere il telefono fare una storia far
sentire questa canzone è questa canzone
è subito subito tutti la vogliono subito
che vogliono sentirlo quindi per dire
oggigiorno è una bomba che esistono i
social è una bomba che esistenza gr
ed è tutto così immediato non serve più
l'etichetta discografica adesso puoi
fare tutto da solo quindi diciamo il
succo della mia storia di questo
discorso è che ognuno di noi può farcela
ognuno può credere in se stessi e fare
qualcosa di di fico
basta avere un computer l'anno scorso è
venuto michele canova mi ha spiegato
proprio questo ha spiegato che serviva
solo un computer e ha ragione
basta solo un computer e tanta voglia di
fare come chi vuole fare il calciatore
vuole fare il pittore eccetera eccetera
e ci siamo
grazie a tutti ho fatto anche dodici
minuti bomba grazie grazie a tutti